[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show it's where america hangs out to
have a conversation about life i'm kid
coleman joined by my colleague dr john
delony we're together
in the studio for you this hour it is a
free phone call triple eight eight two
five five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two five
reminder
some of the questions you've got are
pretty deep pretty sticky sometimes kind
of messy and we will protect your name
and location if that's something that
will give you the courage to call us
john and i love teaming up it's always
fun when we get together and and we'll
take our specialties john of course and
relationships and the mental health
space and and then me in the workspace
work and life are inextricably connected
and a lot of the junk you're dealing
with with relationships has got a work
cost so john and i always love that we
can kind of tackle those together we'll
take those calls today if somebody's
really hurting really confused you got
some emotions you want to deal with uh
we're here for you triple eight eight
two five five two two five doc it's
always fun when we're together you're
ready to rock let's do it man i mean i
know the answer to that question i fully
expected i needed the rocker signal you
didn't give it to me i'm low-key you're
very chill we're gonna do it that's
right you just take some medication yeah
okay no not at all okay
let's go north of the border toronto
canada dylan joins us there dylan how
can we help
hi i uh
so i have just over a quarter million
dollars of consumer debt on top of two
houses that i own whoa um a rental and
my primary residence um
and
250 000 of
consumer debt
yes yeah and then what is that debt how
did you get it
um so i bought a i bought a property um
and then the renovations cost 150 000
just over um
and then
taxes um that i haven't paid for my my
business um that
are fifty thousand dollars and then the
rest just sort of
things here and there so the two houses
you mentioned they're a part of this 250
000.
no
no the house the rehab on one of the
houses
okay exactly all right so let me ask you
a follow-up here so uh uh
is one of the houses paid off what's the
debt on the houses if any
yeah so the one i owe uh or i own sorry
50 50 um with my dad and that one
um we owe
well i my portion is 277 000 and then
the other one is 670 000 that i owe
so you're a million dollars in hawk
yeah yeah i want to make sure we're
dealing with
yeah you're not
thousand dollars a million dollars in
the whole you're a million plus in the
whole leveraged out all right so what's
your question
so my question is um obviously i'm gonna
be selling my um everything rental
property everything good
so then
what um i'm wondering with the debt
snowball should i pay off um
because my i have smaller debts on line
of credits should i pay them off first
because they're smaller or my parents
who i owe 100 000 each do the debt
snowball parents the debt to the parents
is is in the snowball yeah who cares the
one the one caveat here is you said you
owed fifty thousand dollars and i'm
ignorant here in the uss irs what is it
in canada
the cra but yeah i figured that one goes
first yeah the the one you want to roll
out that's the only time we get out of
the baby steps is if you're in hawk to
the government because you're going to
take everything else from you too how
much is the house worth the rental the
one you owe 600 000 on
the rental is worth uh 800 000. the
market's been uh kind to us that way
okay um
and then sell it today sell it this
afternoon tell your dad we're selling
this house
will he do it that's the plan
uh i think so yeah because he's incurred
some debt in our uh recent renovations
how much is the other house
the other house is um
probably worth about 900
um what do you owe on that one 6.75 uh
670.
are you married
uh i have a partner yeah okay do you
have uh kids
no okay how old are you
i'm 26. okay
if i'm you let me back it up if you're
my son or you're my best friend and you
come to me and you're 26 you tell me
what you're telling me
i would tell you to sell
your primary residence your
million-dollar residence i would tell
you to get with your dad and sell that
thing
get squared up with the government
get squared up with all of your debts
have zero have some cash you'll end up
with some cash here if you do this right
and either buy a small home that you can
actually afford based on the income you
produce from your business by the way
which is a business that pays taxes from
now on
or rent for a year or two and just get
your bearings back you're man you are
underwater you know that though right
100 yeah are you just stressed out of
your mind yeah
i don't know how you breathe absolutely
okay then yeah john's right i i couldn't
agree more i would have said the same
thing because of the not just the
financial freedom but can i just throw
the emotional freedom in this i mean
dude which they're obviously tied
together
but this isn't just a numbers play right
this is some health and your future and
and uh if you can fund that emergency
fund and then save up for a little bit
while and rent and then you guys buy
again i mean hey that that's the play
yeah dude your your relationship with
your dad gets better relationship with
the partners relationships everywhere
get better do you able to breathe what
business do you
have uh funnily enough i'm a realtor
well then here's the other thing you
know you know that you can make up
ground quickly
yeah yeah hey dude
i i don't even think this is even up for
vote no i mean well at the end of the
day you're voting john and i are
consulting yes i would sell everything
hey we're talking fresh start imagine
how that would feel january 1st 2022 you
could be out of a million dollars in
debt
have a new smaller place you can take
care of and you will be able to sleep
the whole night without popping awake at
3am how does that sound
it sounds
much better
yes yes yes yes so do it dude yes do it
yes do it do it do it do it man can it
gets it
i you just look at the
instagram or you look at the computer
you look at whatever's on tv and you
just think oh that's the path yeah and i
can just borrow my way too
and man what a blessing we talk to
people who are 60 having this
oh crap moment in the middle of the
night he's 26 man he's got his whole
life ahead of him oh and we're talking
about being a multi-millionaire as a
result of this too absolutely doing it
the right way and being able to be a
multi-millionaire and breathe at the
same time yeah yeah and i love it's got
the income potential with being a
realtor uh i'd be going bananas
because you could fast forward all
everything i love it yeah yeah wow well
john it's uh that time of the year a few
in a few weeks we're going to be doing
what i think is i think one of the great
shows of all time in the history of the
rams show it's our special giving
edition of the ramsay show we want to
hear your stories from you about how you
have paid it forward and given
generously to others maybe you've tipped
a waitress maybe you bought thanksgiving
dinner maybe you bought christmas for
some family that needed it maybe you've
been on the receiving end of an
unbelievable gift or blessing go to
ramseysolutions.com
ask that's ramsey solutions.com
ask and put giving in the subject line
share your story it's going to touch so
many other people we'd love for you to
be a part of this very special show all
right don't go anywhere more of the
ramsay show coming right up
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and serving christian
health cost sharing ministry chm has
shared medical expenses for its members
since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
welcome back america you have joined the
conversation here on the ramsay show i'm
ken coleman he is dr john delany we're
taking your calls about your life your
money your relationships your work
they're all connected aren't they so
we're here to help you the phone number
to jump in is triple eight eight two
five five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two five russell
joins us now in dallas texas
russell how can we help
how are we doing today guys well i'm
living the dream and uh we're here for
you so what's going on perfect perfect
well i have developed some clarity
lately that's really got me energized i
love my job love my life really and i've
decided that the thing that really
speaks to me in my work is being able to
coach people and train people and you
and dr deloney who by the way i'm a
graduate of acu and i was there when uh
dr deloney was there so go wildcats
all right let's not drive by that did
you know him and do you have some
damaging information that you could
reveal to james after the segment um
yeah i personally don't know him but my
wife took his mom's class oh god that
feels all kinds of yuck right there yeah
it's just getting grosser by the second
russell
listen i need this job i haven't paid my
house off yet
yeah russell please please we like you
to sign an nda after the show today
so you're excited uh you love your job
but yeah
yeah well i all i want to know is i see
you guys as leaders
that i want to go into someday like i
want to be a coach
i'm insufferably positive it's one of my
spiritual gifts i listen to personal and
professional development stuff for fun
you guys horse schultz andy stanley
donald miller jim widden like it's just
my thing i love it and so i'm seeing an
opportunity in my job where i can go and
clear that space and press that there
rather than like admin stuff um and so
being at this point with my newfound
clarity and you know excitement about
what i have to do i just want to know
what you guys would do
um if you could talk to your i'm 30 if
you could talk to your 30 year old self
about your current job because you guys
are doing what i'd love to do someday
what would you say what advice do you
guys have well i don't i don't think
that's the question you want from i
don't think you want us to answer that i
think you want us to answer
uh how do you get into that type of
coaching role is that what i'm
understanding that's definitely part of
it i mean yeah yeah well
so
you're an admin assistant or you're in
operations type work right now is that
what i'm understanding
no forgive me i'm in sales you're insane
a lot of it's just like a lot of it is
just like computer work it's looking at
quotes moving on to the next thing it's
not face to face in front of people okay
so so i'll partially answer the question
if i could talk to my 30 year old self
and i knew that i was going to do what
i'm doing now
which at the time i didn't that's why i
do what i do now right i thought i was
heading down a different track uh i
would delineate the specifics
uh as follows
do i want to coach speak write
do i want to do counseling
and then
uh of those areas and i'm trying to pull
out your list uh who is it that i want
to coach or counsel or speak to or write
to what problem or desire do they have
and then how do i want to come about
helping them get that that's a that's
that's what i would tell my
third-year-old self because i think you
got to understand that and really learn
it before you just go well i want to
coach or i want to do what you guys do
john and i do what we do
because of the problems we want to solve
right and i think that's first and
foremost john anything you'd add to that
yeah the thing i would add man is my 30
year old self and you can go back and
ask some of our your classmates who were
around me dude that guy was
hell-bent on being the leader of a thing
being at the top of a thing interesting
being around influencers and being
around presidents and doing writing and
getting published it was all these
external things and what i would tell my
30 year old self is brother you need a
decade of being in the middle of the
night in hospitals with people sitting
behind closed doors helping marriages
falling apart you need to do that work
for 10 years before you have any
business giving other people wisdom on
how they can make decisions and so
a mantra i give myself is find the
learning anywhere you are so if you're
grinding out as a salesman right now why
you're gonna and ken's gonna walk you
through the steps while you start
leaning into what coaching is gonna look
like make sure you're keeping close
notes of what you're experiencing what
the people you're calling on or
experiencing talk to them about their
families when you're trying to sell
something to an executive somewhere talk
to them about the job they're in what
they love about what they don't that a
that's going to help you sell sales b is
going to help you develop relationships
and see you're going to get to learn
it's the proximity you're going to get
to learn how this job actually works the
one that you actually want to do someday
russell do you know who you want to
coach or counsel
yeah i'd like to do executive i'd like
to do executive kind of business
development stuff but like you said
earlier it's all kind of intertwined so
you're correct i do need to delineate
and specify before i just attack well
you're close though so you have to give
a little bit more homework in stage one
so i teach this through seven stages how
do you how do you do what you were born
to do and experience tremendous meaning
stage one is get clear i think you're 90
clear i think you got to dive into okay
i want to help business leaders i want
to mentor them maybe i want to walk with
them and be an accountability person i
mean who knows you got to kind of
delineate that a little bit further by
going through what's the problem that a
executive has that i most get excited
about solving i think if you get into
that one right there and you get some
clarity there that's really huge now you
go okay i gotta get qualified you gotta
do some homework what are the
qualifications in the industry
yeah first and then second like john
said i want to see you actually lead a
team and lead maybe a division or two
before we start
unless you've been a business leader
know that's what's going on there right
yeah right right it's like the marketing
it's like the marketing professor at
college who's actually never had to
market anything they just studied theory
theory is great but at some point theory
must meet brick reality
yeah and so
i think those are the steps for you is
to actually begin to lead
and uh and learn how to lead now here's
the good news ross i want to encourage
you on something you've been following
and and learning how to follow is vital
to learning how to lead
uh but i do think if you're gonna coach
leaders i think you need to understand
the moccasins that they put on yeah
what's it like to walk in their shoes to
deal with that
i think that's really really important
yeah i'll never forget i have
several close buddies who were had
positions that i wanted in universities
and then i finally got one and it was a
few months in and i realized
oh they earned that money
but there's you sleep differently when
the whole thing rests on you right when
you and you it's easy to see that title
on that position but there i i wouldn't
have been half as good at helping walk
alongside people had i not
laid in bed at night with that weight on
my own chest it's 100 right or i know
what it's like to be sitting through
dinner and be completely not present
because my head's back at the office
whatever so you've got to spend a season
in in that time yeah um that's why i
mean you walk the journey you know what
it's like to lay awake at 3am and think
that i wasted my life there you go i'm
not doing something that fires me up
during the day yeah and then i know what
it's like to go seven years ago
yeah and then figure out what i think it
is yep confirm it and then go now what
yeah right and then really suck at it
and not get much opportunity for a while
he's like so that's the point
i don't think you need a ton of
experience to actually lead somebody but
i do think you need a good amount of
experience to coach somebody who's
leading there's the difference that's
right and the i we tell all the time
dave talks to is one of the only ceos if
not the only ceo in the united states
that
spends three hours a day with a
frontline customer right think how
different burger king would be if the
ceo took lunch orders every day five
days a week but the andy stanley's of
the world and the john maxwell they've
sat with people
for years and years and years which
gives them the wisdom too it's not just
a bunch of theories and a bunch of books
that they read right yeah you got time
for a quick social media question
real quick let's see real fast
how can i move on from a broken
friendship and business relationship
with my sister-in-law we're still around
each other and she doesn't seem sorry
for what she's caused
oh man um at some point
if somebody if you're in a relationship
with somebody you're going to be around
them and that's just going to be life i
always suggest two things number one
you've got to go have an upfront
conversation
and just call is what is and that it's
that unspoken secret stuff that causes
drama
and um that that
true conversation will cause drama too
but at least it's out on the open here's
where everybody is and number two you
have to decide every day to set it down
i am not gonna carry my drama into this
christmas event i'm not going to carry
my drama into this thing i don't like
her she doesn't like me
partridge in a pear tree i'm going to go
about being a respectful adult and move
on with my life i'm not going to carry
that yeah i'm not going to give her that
control my life there it is because you
can't control it she's going to react
it's driving you bananas but by by
letting her speak into my soul i'm
giving her permission to ruin my that's
a what a waste of a life cheer up man
ah there it is cheers and one quick
answer how to never have tension at
thanksgiving again you just saw it it's
that incident uncle larry it's his fault
it will fall
go to go to go out to eat somewhere on
thanksgiving there it is that works too
all right don't go anywhere he is dr
john delaney i'm ken coleman and this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague dr john dolone
we're taking your calls about life
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the phone number to jump in
triple eight eight two five
five two two five and uh i look across
in the lobby and i see adam and vicki
they're on the debt free stage welcome
to the ramsay show thank you so i guess
since you're standing there you're here
to do a debt free scream yes sir you see
how sharp i am
very very very few kids in honors
classes
ken was an honors club so true where are
you guys from raleigh north carolina
raleigh all right and uh let's hear the
story how much debt did you pay off
uh we paid off uh 156 thousand one
hundred and five dollars whoa
how long did that take 18 months 18
months wow whoa
okay what do you guys tell me the range
of income then we'll figure out what you
do well range of income 280 000 to 305
000 whoa we're not playing around what
do you guys do for a living real estate
quality assurance
and i work in enterprise risk nice
so i always love to hear the story here
280 to 305. what was the cause for the
bump
[Music]
um god is good
okay i really like that i'm gonna press
you i mean was it just a natural race
did you go after a promotion what
happened uh just natural natural stuff
great fantastic all right uh and uh
18 months ago
you guys decided we're gonna get after
this what what spurred this on
well for the next 30 minutes i would
like to talk about yes
the precursor story no the the it really
started um
we were on on the show in 2015. oh wow
so we are repeat uh uh screamers um
and we had paid off 89
775
uh in 2015
and that was credit card debt in cars
and i was a personal financial wrecking
ball
and my wife uh was patient and loving
and kind and and uh the dave ramsey
teaching helped us get through that wait
a minute so is this your house yeah this
is our house
for the house all right so we got done
with all that debt and we just went
straight into uh let's let's save money
um
and we did that and then my wife said
hey hon um
i'd like to pay off the house too and i
thought is this ever going to end
so no in june of 2020 we pivoted to the
house and we just went gazelle intense
and you know let's uh let's knock it out
let's not have that debt anymore and so
i am
we
longed for this day to come here with
the mortgage satisfaction notice filed
at the courthouse
and say we're
totally dead wow that is so fantastic
wow that is really cool how does that
feel
amazing
have you have you received the first
paycheck where you didn't have to pay
your mortgage yet yes
how does that feel when all that money
deposits and you realize oh we can just
do whatever we want to with this yeah
we're still doing our budgets though so
we're being good yeah we still have
goals and i think that was another
important message for us is you know not
losing that momentum so
you know we focus a lot on that that
nasty consumer debt but it really feels
good
not to owe anybody anything and own all
your own money and not rent it and so um
it's exciting because now those that
baby step seven the building wealth and
the giving now now seems so much
more fun okay so the question that pops
up for me is
how was gazelle intense different if at
all when we just paid off the house so
having paid off all other consumer debt
prior doing your debt free screen then
it's like let's do this was there any
and do any different things you've done
it once before it's kind of like being a
millionaire second time over curious
what's the answer to that
so uh
you know what the first one felt
good because
uh it i felt a lot of guilt um had
accumulated a lot of debt i had
squandered a lot of income
and and so that was a guilt release
moment
this is people don't feel as guilty
about mortgage debt but this feels
so good because it's like it's all gone
now yeah it's all gone um
we're two two people with no college
degrees yeah um who scratching through
life and we don't owe anybody anything
anymore and now
we can get to that generous level uh
that we want to be at and that's
exciting because that's more we feel
more of what god's called us to do we
can now financially fund
and so um
this this feels this feels great and
we've got some great friends um that
have joined us uh that have walked this
journey with us and uh are on their own
journey and uh we have some friends uh
back at home uh that are in that same
position and we're coming back in july
when they're going to celebrate their
debt debt free screams right so the
answer is this ever going to end i don't
think it is you guys are just going to
keep bringing more people to do debt
free screams now that's like your new
thing and when i told our kids you know
when we we had a whole group together
and we did a mortgage burning party and
i threw the mortgage in the fire that's
fine um and it felt great but then it
hit me
this is a corvette zr1 that i could have
had
right
but but it feels so much better to have
a house and and and we own it so
i i wish the people
listening could see them
it's it's almost like you have to be
strapped to the stage just floating over
there yeah having paid off every single
thing you own tell me about the journey
in your marriage i know there's a little
bit of frustration a little bit of come
on a little bit of do we make three
hundred thousand dollars i can drive a
corvette for god's sake man yeah i mean
that's a lot of money and there's it's a
different level of why are we working
like this if we're not going to enjoy it
what was that like for your marriage
they both looked at each other like
there's a pattern going on
yeah yes no she's emphatic that i do
most of talking so okay um anyways uh
the
you know it will you ask me that
question again
how did this impact your marriage
so we've been married 32 years
we got married when i was 19 she was 18.
i was in the marine corps we had a
pregnant three months later i mean we
made
so many choices that people probably
would classify as bad
and then to compound financial
mismanagement on top of that
but
she is uh a saint and
she has been loving and patient and kind
through this she's frugal i'm an idiot
and so
she her patience and love helped us get
through this and so that just built our
marriage meaning that she was there when
i was doing all the dumb stuff and i bet
i bet if she would she would talk off
air she would say that you've been there
for her too so man just two incredible
rock stars yeah what a what a gift so
fun speaking of gifts uh we've got two
books for you one is a copy of dave's
book total money makeover and that is a
gift to you to give to somebody else
because you guys are definitely looking
for other couples to influence and
you've obviously modeled that already
the second is dave's new book which
comes out in january baby steps
millionaires so you can get it right now
pre-sell but we're going to give that
book to you because you guys are on your
way there obviously and you have done it
and uh so we're really proud of you so
that's a gift to you so you guys ready
to go yeah but i want to say one more
thing well sure all right i want to also
shout out to my my kids my four boys
because they all graduated from college
they all graduated with some student
debt
and they all paid off their student debt
within two years of graduation they went
rice and beans paid it off and they live
debt-free lifestyle tell us their names
uh
chad ryan cody and kyle way to go way to
go fellas you did good mom and dad that
is awesome that's legacy stuff right
there all right here we go adam and
vicki from raleigh north carolina they
paid off 156
in 000.18 months the house this time
around making between 280 and 305
thousand dollars adam vicki it's your
turn let's hear a debt free screen
three two one we're
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
totally i like that what a great story
they're debt free except their house
then they say let's get after the house
but listen to this then they say let's
go back and do another one but listen
they did something really hard it took
him a long time the first time and then
any other hard project they go to go
through the rest of their life they can
go yeah we do that 18 months we'll do
that that's cool we'll knock it out and
then they're four boys oh man seeing mom
and dad model the way that's incredible
that's legacy man that's what we all
want great stuff what a great couple all
right hey here's some great news we have
more of the ramsay show coming up don't
move
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back america you are joining the
ramsay show i'm ken coleman joined by my
colleague dr john dolone we're taking
your calls the shower
about your life triple eight eight two
five five two two five triple eight
eight two five
five two two five now uh i love the old
nursery rhymes the old children stories
and i think if we were to take a vote of
the entire population john that the
tortoise and the hare would clearly be a
top three top five for sure we all love
it and it's one of our favorites around
here because it really is
i think the theme of what we teach here
at ramsey solutions that's slow and
steady like the tortoise wins the race
every time certainly in money and in
your work and your relationships every
area of your life
and we sometimes though we uh kind of
romance the story and we forget why the
hair actually didn't win
because he actually took some time off
and took a nap he just got off the path
he didn't stay on the path and keep
moving he put off what he knew he should
do in favor of what he wanted to do so
for all you tortoises out there we know
it's hard to keep pushing fighting and
hacking away especially when you see all
these other hairs quitting jobs
deferring student loan payments and
financing fancy stuff so
if you'd like to get a boost at this
time of year we'd like you to take part
of a ramsey christmas cash giveaway this
year we're giving away up to five
thousand dollars you can enter at
ramseysolutions.com
giveaway that's ramsey solutions dot com
slash giveaway and you can keep entering
every day to increase your chances of
winning and if you need an extra dose of
motivation just in time for the new year
uh our team is featuring a new deal
every day this week so today only when
you buy oh that says me
my book from paycheck to purpose for
just 20 bucks you'll get the career
assessment for free this is a great gift
for somebody who's looking at new year
new career we're just giving that away
yeah yeah yeah yeah i need a new pair of
shoes so that's not going to help yeah
it's going to help somebody else which
is what it's all about but kelly has a
pair of christmas shoes she does it's
her favorite song look
so anyway if you'd like to make 2022
your best wealth building year yet shop
our one day deal at our online store at
ramseysolutions.com
today all right let's get to the phones
triple eight eight two five five two two
five chicago illinois is where we go to
talk to tim tim how can we help
oh hey guys how are you we're living the
dream tim what's going on with you
uh so
what i'd like to purchase at home
another home um i currently own the home
that i live in now
and uh
i'd like a bigger nicer place and i just
want to make sure that it's something
that's financially responsible for me to
do at this time
it's a little bit complicated because i
own a company
um and and historically i've dumped
every bit of money i've i've ever made
back into it so it feels a bit guilty to
start taking
taking from it now
wait a second
you mean you're talking about you pay
yourself a salary but traditionally
beyond the salary you've never paid
yourself anything as the owner
i paid myself dividends uh but they've
been
pretty small for example last year i
reinvested 309 000
of what could have been my personal
income back into the company
uh just to grow the company debt free
did it roi
yeah oh yeah so what's complicated about
this the amount of money that you would
have to give yourself
is way higher than you've ever done
before but it would also allow you to
buy that bigger house in a much better
financial play is that what's going on
that's right
that's right well what's complicated
uh well i do have um i do have
some loans through the business and i
actually probably misspoke when i said
debt free but um i've i've kept the debt
to a very minimum
um i owe 400 000 on a building a
commercial building that i just
purchased
uh 220 000 um is in one mortgage and the
rest is in an sba 504.
um the 220 balloons in five years so i'm
i'm a little bit worried i'd like to get
that mortgage paid off because that's
where balloons and five years so we
pause on the house
business get the business healthy and
pay it off man that that five year clock
is ticking that's why you're nervous so
no on the house right now no you don't
need a house
you want one
does it make a difference that the the
220 is not
in an incredible amount of money for the
amount of income that i have
reverse engineer that question since
it's since you make so much money just
pay it off you know what i mean
right right well
yeah so the company does 2.5 million um
my bottom line is about 15 so i'm at
about 375 000 a year that's yeah that's
right that's
right historically i have not okay um
but i could but i could i have 20 000 in
emergency funds 120 000
in um
in a savings account that was supposed
to go towards a down payment and then
another 200 000 in liquid capital to run
the company
yeah um and then of course i do my 195
to 401 6000 to
ira
you're the one that's making this
complex this is really simple we told
you what you should do and then you
asked us another question and i think it
comes down to
um what is it that you uh are
leaning on or counting on
to not pay this debt off
you're pa you're just counting on
nothing ever going wrong
i mean
you know what he's right john we've not
had a pandemic recently that changed the
whole world nothing like that happened
no
i mean this is ludicrous and you know
it's ludicrous but i also know you
really really really want to buy a house
yeah so hear us say
we know that you're probably not going
to do what we're suggesting but what
we're suggesting is be debt-free in your
business in six months or less and then
save and then go buy a house
and if you have if you've got reserve
capital for your business and you're
running a debt-free company and you've
got next year lined up and you want to
take a bigger dividend as the ceo and
owner of your company don't make it an
identity statement that i don't ever pay
myself anything
that's silly that's that's a recipe for
burnout
choose to it's a recipe for resentment
choose to take care of yourself in a
season i don't have any problem that at
all yeah i mean i i would sum it up with
this i really want to meet lover's pizza
sometimes at midnight
it's not a good idea yeah don't do that
no no
so he really wants a house and then keep
the debt alive on his business don't do
it that's right you'll regret in the
morning for sure that's my point there's
just nothing good is gonna come out of
that situation that's right
and i think sometimes we try to like
talk ourselves into well what if what if
what if what if so who knows uh let's go
to ken in columbia south carolina next
ken how can we help
hey how you doing um
i uh am about to uh celebrate my 15 year
anniversary uh coming up this summer
and uh i am trying to decide uh
what kind of trip and if i should take a
trip
um thinking about new york uh and some
other
trips and i'm just not sure that um i
should put
that kind of money into it my wife's a
little more conservative than i am uh
i'm i i am i guess i would say i'm in
the middle
um so i'm just trying to ask for some
advice on that
well also the budget what's the budget
telling you that you guys can actually
afford to do
uh
i mean i think yeah i mean we're okay on
that i mean we do uh do you have
retirement we you ready to pay bills you
know we all yo is the cars right now so
i guess the reason i asked you that ken
is i want to kind of get you to walk
back into this thing if you guys have a
budget and the budget's actually working
and it's allowing you to move forward
and you've budgeted for this trip a 19th
anniversary trip and you can afford it
then do it
yeah yeah yeah am i missing something
what's your debt load you said you owe
on you owe two car payments
yeah we owe two car payments how much do
you own the car uh we uh we we owe about
30 together how much money do you make
what's your annual salary
uh together it's uh rotted 100.
yeah so can i tell you can i be totally
transparent with you
i have celebrated my 19th anniversary
last summer and my wife and i have some
financial goals we're trying to burn
through this thing and get my house paid
off so you know what we did for ours
hang on to your hat brother we went to a
koa
in north carolina it's a very nice one
though it was a real nice one but it was
a couple hundred bucks you know why
because we want to be out of debt that
was that was the decision that we made
and we don't have any consumer debt like
you don't have any car payments like
y'all do but that was a choice we made
and so we're going to set ourselves up
for the 20th this summer
let me i did not catch that i don't know
how i missed it
i must not have been listening well so i
need to clarify that yeah you don't need
to be going on the anniversary trip you
need to get rid of those cars 20 is a
bigger one than 19 anyway so i'd
recommend saving that one so save it uh
we're going gonna work the debt snowball
is what we do that's right and so it's
rice and beans let's knock this thing
out sorry i missed that pal i'm glad you
couldn't koas are awesome dude
campgrounds rock man
all right folks
this hour is in the books i want to
thank our producer james shiles our
associate producer and paul screener
gina jenna sears rather and dr john
delaney for hanging out with me but
mostly you america thank you this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country to find a
station near you head to thermzyshow.com
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting for the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show it's where america hangs out to
have a conversation about life i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr john
delony we are here for you this hour it
is a free phone call to jump in
aaa
825-5225 what do you want to talk about
what do you need to talk about
feeling a little bit alone feeling like
maybe there's not much hope at all john
and i are here to encourage and equip
you we'd love to hear from you today
triple eight eight two five five two two
five the phone lines are open caitlyn is
going to start us off the shower in
knoxville tennessee caitlin how can we
help
hi karen hi john uh thank you so much
for taking my call um so i
just moved here this year from
california i'm a single mom with two
kids
and when i moved here i was able to get
a job in the same
field that i was working in in
california which was in human services
and when i got to this job i was really
excited about it
and it turned out to be pretty toxic
environment and the management was not
great the way that they did things was a
lot different than what i
was used to um and i felt like
instead of being able to
treat people
as people and as humans and families
they
kind of were treating them as just
numbers and that wasn't something that i
could
kind of do
and as i kept going through
um
it just got worse and worse so i ended
up
quitting the job and now
i am just doing like delivery driving
for four dash and instacart and those
things but
while it's paying the bills i'm also in
debt and i'm trying to figure out what
my next steps would be
to kind of get back
into like having a career that
um
gives me purpose and that is going to
glorify the kingdom okay let's uh let's
detail that out i think you know what it
is
uh was this social work when you said
human services was it social work was it
government or was it non-profit
government work it was government
and um
let's just remove whatever you've done
in the past and let's look forward for a
second what's the kind of work that that
would give you that real sense of
purpose doing what you know you're born
to do
yeah so i took your assessment ken um
and
basically what that
came out to me was everything that i
thought i was wanting to do
um i had my bachelor's degree in
psychology which is why i'm happy that
john's on the phone too because i
um i've been listening to him as well as
you
um and i just i'm trying to figure out
because i
when i was in college getting this
degree i went through a class where
they're basically like oh well if you
stop at bachelor's degree you can kind
of like be a receptionist or you know do
all these kind of entry-level things but
you're not going to really go anywhere
unless you get like a doctorate or a phd
you know like
higher education which i as a single mom
like with that i'm
that's not really so let me focus let me
focus you for a second i know that
that's a tough journey and john can
speak to that uh very very specifically
but what i want to do is i want to get
an understanding of what would you do if
there was no debt if you didn't have to
get qualified
who would you want to counsel who would
you want to serve
um
i originally originally when i went to
school i wanted to be a marriage and
family counselor
um
but just i really just want to help
i don't know because i really
um
i've kind of been all over the place
i've wanted to help veterans i've wanted
to help
um people with mental issues i've wanted
to help the homeless okay great i just
all right great that's all good news all
right here's what i want you to do all
right john i want you to weigh in on
this because you're the the actual
psychologist but from a tactical
standpoint
i think you're a little bit overwhelmed
by all the different possibilities that
have popped into your head on who you
want to help but is it true that you
would just want to counsel people you
want to sit knee to knee with them look
at them eyeball to eyeball and listen
and learn and coach them up and counsel
them and take them to a place of
transformation is that true
true okay so that's the what you're
really clear and confident on the what
correct
yeah and you know the why don't you
yeah yeah
so the who
and the how john i would normally say if
you weren't sitting next to me and i'm
deferring here because of your expertise
and training but i would say this is the
good old-fashioned proximity principle
on the starting sentences just let's
hang out with some people right who are
actually counseling veterans some of
these names and the types of people and
the demographics has popped in her mind
and i would suggest that she either
volunteers or tries to you know get
around some of those folks
and verify
who kind of pulls into her heart the
most what would you say to that yeah
two things one i i've heard this
throughout my entire career i also
taught in graduate programs for mental
health professionals
um people going back and getting their
phds and their master's degrees i hear
folks who want to be helpers
and i've heard that what you just said i
want to help this group i don't try to
help that group and help that group
where that falls inside out is people
think that when i help the right group
it will be easy it will be a job that i
just go home feeling fulfilled all the
time or all the management's all great
and that's simply inaccurate
helping any group is hard and it takes
your soul it's draining it's challenging
it's why i go spend weekends in the
woods it's just tough right and i'm not
even doing like a true therapy i'm
talking on the on the stinking radio man
not like my buddies who are in the in
the trenches here so
getting understanding that your feelings
this like just a number it's just that
man some of that is the reality of
working with people in these situations
the other thing i would recommend is
this you have boxed yourself into i'm a
single mom i can't do this now that
there is some validity to you cannot sit
for a licensing exam unless you have a
graduate degree that's the world we're
in
so
you're in a college town you could get a
job at one of the universities as a
receptionist as a secretary as an admin
and take advantage of their free tuition
program that's what i did for my second
phd in counseling uh university paid for
it because i was a university employee
let me jump in super fast walmart and
target are also offered there you go so
i mean if you want to get out of a car
and be safe in a store they're offering
college tuition as well john's
absolutely right you can do this but we
got to get you out of debt as well
that's right so you know i listen
getting out of debt
is your primary goal
the psychology degree and the counseling
opportunity and the people you want to
help will still be there but you must
get stable first
do you understand
yeah because it feels overwhelming right
now you go i know what i want to do but
how in the world am i going to get there
we're going to get to the same way
everybody else did but you got to get
out of debt
you're already clear so now we got to
get out of debt
then we get qualified
then we get connected and we get started
and i think spending some time with some
other mental health professionals
counselors who specialize spending time
with them they're also going to give you
some wonderful insight into the problems
they're solving and there may be one or
more problems or type of people that you
get more excited about helping whether
it's marriage and family or vets or
whatever right here's a secret that i
learned are you ready
yeah one of the best training programs i
ever had for working with in mental
health
uh in that world
was working fast food
here's why
you learn to talk to everybody and you
get to see people who are trying to
smile through a lot of pain you get to
see people who are just joyful you get
to interact with people you get 10
seconds to make somebody's day a little
bit brighter or a little bit worse and i
get to choose that and so whatever work
you do
whatever work you do we'll be in service
to one day you sitting across
a couch from somebody saying how can i
help
and don't minimize those experiences and
interactions yeah really good
thank you for the call katelyn you're
gonna help a lot of people this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr john
dolone we are here for you this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the phone number to jump in
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five and the phone lines are
open john uh this freaked me out
christmas is two weeks away i don't know
where the year went
okay i mean it's flying i i sound like
my dad's saying that but it's really
it's it's really moving fast right and
at ramsey solutions we've been in a
christmas frame of mind for a while now
we're having a great time handing out
cash as a part of our annual christmas
cash giveaway
uh because if you haven't experienced it
yet uh giving is the most fun you'll
ever have with money every year we
celebrate christmas with our ramsay show
listeners with an awesome tradition the
ramsay christmas cash giveaway this year
we're giving away 500 every week and a
grand prize of five thousand dollars you
can enter every day to increase your
chances of winning enter now at
ramseysolutions.com
giveaway
and
we know you're planning to do some
giving you're looking for christmas
ideas that's why our team is featuring a
new deal every day this week and today
is my day uh well that's fun my name is
i know they put this in front of me so
i'd have to read it i feel like you
should have to read it talking about my
book but the latest book uh from
paycheck to purpose bestseller it's now
available for just twenty dollars you
can get my career assessment along with
us for free so this is the perfect gift
for somebody who's not happy in their
work or maybe uh they are looking
forward to dreaming and they want to get
some confirmation this would be a great
gift uh for the job hunter on your list
so uh this is your last week to order
gifts and get it in time for christmas
so shop our one day deal online at
ramseysolutions.com that's
ramseysolutions.com
all right let's go to tracy in
louisville kentucky tracy how can we
help
hey thank you so much for taking my call
you bet um so
my husband is a combat veteran who's
been diagnosed with ptsd and
schizoaffective disorder
and the longer he has been out of the
service
the more difficult it is for us to
communicate
and be on the same page um
especially when it comes to our finances
um
hang on a second take a breath take a
breath take a breath take a breath take
a breath
i'm getting a cardio workout just
sitting in my car my heart's beating so
fast bless your heart you're good we're
here with you take your time
how long have you been sitting on this
diagnosis
since 2016.
can i say the obvious out loud
it is hard to
love somebody and live with somebody
just get to effective order right
yeah
you still love him of course you do you
love him to the end of time
but you've been through hell the last
few years haven't you
yeah yeah it's hard and he's
he's contemplating divorce yeah
yep
and there's probably a part of him that
deep down in his soul thinks that your
life would be better without him am i
right
yeah because he's also very um
he's almost taken his life twice too
that's right yeah that feeling of
burdensome
of burden oh i'm sorry so so sorry what
a mess
what's his care regimen look like
um
right now like
um he's not on medications we tried that
route
and um the va just basically threw pills
at him and the side effects were worse
off than dealing with it without
medication
um he was meeting with our pastor for
for counseling and our pastor is not a
licensed therapist but more of like a
companion yeah um he needs some true
trauma counseling in a um
he's gonna have to get a doctor and a
psychiatrist that'll walk alongside him
it's not just gonna throw pills at him
but this is a tough tough road to hoe
is is he giving up hope
i don't think so no he's still here
yeah yeah yeah
oh man um yeah this is i mean you know
this and this isn't why you called but
um
this would fall into a very limited
number of situations in my world that
would be a red a red alert situation i'm
going to call not the va i'm going to
get the money i'm going to figure the
the finance part out but we're going to
sit with a psychiatrist to our medical
doctor that we trust and it will um
that somebody recommends that this will
listen to you and we'll start small and
build up the right way and
get into some trauma counseling asap
what i want to tell you is i know folks
in that situation and there is help on
the other side of it
um it feels like
everybody's drowning on this side of it
i'm so sorry you're going through that
do you all handle your finances together
are you the primary person who handles
it what's that look like
i'm actually a ranking preferred coach
um
it's more along the lines of um i do the
budget and include him in it
um
and
he sees money differently than i do
because of the
near-death experiences that he's had
right that money to him is just
it's not
tied to a tangible feature i guess would
be a way of describing it like he
doesn't view it the same way
that i do or somebody with the sound of
mine does right it's it's just another
thing essentially is the way he
described it
well he's he's seen
he's got a very tangible
he's breathed the air of there's not
going to be a tomorrow
and so it's really easy to fall into
since there's not going to be tomorrow
let's live it up today let's spend
everything right
yeah
yeah um and again whenever you've got a
brain that all ptsd is your body
responding in the present as though the
trauma you experienced in the past is
happening now
and what a good trauma counselor do and
by the way um there's a number of
programs and study there's so many
different routes these days that they
didn't have five years ago 10 years ago
15 years ago there's some really
extraordinary stuff on the horizon i'm
not in the horizon it's already here um
man when you get your body to calm down
in the present then the future looks
real and right now the future's just not
real it's it's a myth right
and you know that you live in that
um
is he accumulating debt or just spending
all the money that's coming yeah it's
just a hole in the checkbook what's what
is it
um
so he's accumulating a little bit of
debt
my name's not on any of it except for
the house
um we have like our joint savings he's
got his own credit card that he's slowly
accumulating dead on and then
um
does he know this is a problem or is
there a philosophical issue here
he knows that it's a problem for me
okay
would he honor you enough to give away
the credit card like when i work with
folks with bipolar one of the things is
you got to put some roadblocks in front
of you right i know that things get hard
on your manic or when you're low but you
got to put some roadblocks in front of
you is he willing to do that or no
no he's not okay
we've had that conversation and
um he's at this time now okay
so here's where
things get hard and i want to give you
two pieces of wisdom here okay number
one i want you to let the shame
that you're a ramsay preferred coach and
you're married to someone who's
struggling let that go yeah you're not
failing anybody okay
you're carrying this thing around that
you should be this because you're
licensed i mean you're certified as that
man you are in
hell
both of you are and it's hard okay we're
walking with you we're not putting your
fingers at you okay will you release
that shame to set it down
yes thank you okay and the second thing
here is
you
and you alone need to go see somebody
and i say you alone your husband clearly
needs to go but you can't make that you
can't force that you can't will that
and you got a guidance
go ahead
i am seeing our church counselor i want
you to become a trauma therapist i want
you to go see a trauma therapist you've
been married to somebody with ptsd and
schizoaffective disorder if that's even
a true diagnosis
and um
you need to go see somebody because
you've had whether it's secondary trauma
or true trauma you've seen it all and
you've experienced it all and you've
woke up in the middle of the night next
to somebody who's screaming and who's
sweating and who's bleeding you've been
there too now
i want you to go see a trauma therapist
somebody knows what they're doing who's
licensed and who will walk alongside you
it's not going to be as hard as you
think it is but it's something that
you've got to do for you
thank you for your service we love you
we love you we love you keep us in the
loop if we keep walking alongside you
we're here for you tracy don't give up
you have so much value
don't give up
do not give up this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman i'm joined by dr john dolone
this hour as we take your calls about
live triple eight eight two five five
two two five the number is triple eight
eight two five
five two two five and out in the lobby
of ramsey solutions
justin and taylor i guess you guys are
here to do a debt-free screen
yes sir all right let's go let's hear
the story how much debt did you pay off
eighty-nine thousand two hundred
ninety-one dollars all right that is
awesome eighty-nine thousand dollars and
how long did it take you to pay it off
24 months 24 months and the range of
income
uh we started out making 118 000 a year
and uh we when we finished we were
making 213 000
and along the way we started a business
that promises to continue to grow that
number come on future so i'm guessing
the business is what gave us the big
bump
uh well it was part of it we both uh i
had a career change and my wife has
gotten some promotions during that time
what do you guys do
um i'm in economic development okay and
i'm in sales all right very nice
economic development going on in dallas
texas right now
real slow down there in dallas right now
that is fantastic all right so uh 24
months ago
uh well what was the debt let's talk
about that what was included in the 89
000. i think everything i mean mostly
student loans okay
credit cards
uh one vehicle
yeah and then i thought it would be a
great idea to uh
get a 401k loan to roll roll some of
that credit card debt up why not it's
all normal everything you just said is
very normal yeah so you guys were normal
okay great
24 months ago you guys start into this
journey what led to this
well really the lord put us in just a
time of transition um i transitioned out
of the military um we transitioned from
jobs um justin left coaching he was a
texas high school football coach
you left the mother church man
i did yeah
yeah so just
just noticing just all the transition
that the lord was putting us in and with
that being said like
i we got planted into a new church and
all i wanted to do was get involved i
was like okay i just want to serve i
want to serve i want to serve that's my
heart i just want to do that
and so we get into this new church to
get planted and i'm like let's jump in
let's go and justin um he's a little
tired you know after being a football
coach like you're it's all the time and
so um
i started praying lord lord please just
you know convict my husband's heart i
wanna i wanna serve let's serve together
and so one day he comes to me and he
says you know i'm feeling convicted
about something and i'm like yes okay
lord this is it like we was what we've
been praying for and
he just he goes you know i mean i think
i stopped long enough like talking to
god for hear him say i'm feeling
convicted about our finances and i was
like okay
that's not what we talked about but um
but no i mean that's what really kind of
opened my eyes that you know we were
making you know good money but
not not seeing the fruits of it wow yeah
i want to say first thank you for your
service to our country you're a great
american appreciate that thank you and
then i got to say to coach over there
clear eyes full hearts can't lose
got to get that out before we go any
further yeah
so
wow so uh so you guys say all right
we're gonna we're gonna get after this
did you take the financial peace
university class i mean how did you dive
in so
um taylor's dad had given her a copy of
the total money makeover here it is when
she graduated high school and it was a
great paperweight for about 11 years
you just burned through that one huh
yeah
well you know i put it i did it with all
college students or
fresh college freshmen i'm like okay i'm
gonna put in a box i'll come back and
get it later oh sure and i'm pretty sure
at some point uh her dad saw it at our
house was like yeah i gave this taylor
forever ago i don't i don't know if she
ever read it so i ended up reading it
and that's about the time i came back to
her and said hey look i think uh you
know
we got to make some changes because i
had just left coaching transitioned in
sales and was making more money than i'd
ever made yeah she had just gotten a big
promotion she was making more money
she'd ever made and at the end of the
month we still were just sitting there
going where's all our money going yeah
and so it really came down to us getting
frustrated to the point that we knew a
change had to be made and so we
we decided to take fbu and um
you know after that the rest is
history
that i don't want to stand in front of a
former
of a veteran and a texas high school
football coach yeah y'all are going to
get crap done in a short amount of time
so what was the hardest sacrifice you
made as a couple
um i think really so we ended up selling
our house um and we moved in with my mom
and step dad
whoa
so close quarter with two children two
dogs um so y'all were serious serious we
were like let's do this
yeah we uh i basically kind of
calculated out like hey look if we if we
just
you know stick our nose to the
grindstone
we sell the house
in this many months we'll we'll be able
to
pay everything off and buy a new house
and so
we uh we did that we paid everything off
and we moved into a new home and uh it
feels a lot better to be in a new home
with none of the other stuff
uh attached to us that's incredible wow
so what's the key what would you tell
other couples that are sitting there
going yeah we might do it we've seen
this book uh up in the up in the uh
attic a few times yeah i would say um
one
obviously communication being
in alignment i mean that's probably
first and foremost but being able to
just give it to god i mean that was
probably one of the biggest things for
us is just making sure that
we kept him first and foremost and then
our marriage and our kids and everything
else and everything lined up just the
way we needed it too yeah and i would
say just
understanding that it's not gonna be a
perfect journey you know like most
things in life it it at the end it looks
really perfect but along the way there's
definitely some conversations where
you're like what are we doing you know
well and how do you
how would you counsel somebody
i mean you're a former high school
football coach you have to have at least
an f 250 if not bigger and you're the
veteran so clearly you got a jeep that's
jacked up out in the parking lot how do
you how do you make those sacrifices
i mean you gotta have gone to have a
grab a drink with some buddies who are
still coaching and they're like you're
at your in-laws hat what yeah how how
would you tell somebody to work through
some of that comparison issues yeah i
think i think you know comparison is the
thief of joy like you know
a lot of people will tell you that but i
think the the number one thing for us
was just understanding the the
long-range goals the dreams
i think when you're in alignment about
what you want the future to look like
and and how you're going to get there
then it makes the each step along the
way a lot easier to
to do together oh man well it's awesome
i love it i love it so who are your
biggest cheerleaders along the journey
well
uh the group we got over here with us
obviously the the grandparents uh that
gave us the book and then let us crash
their pad for nine months
that always helps yeah that's awesome
and the kiddos in the journey as well
yeah so we actually had one child
throughout the journey ax was born like
right i guess
in the middle of it yeah
that was pretty cool transition april
2nd 2020 so it was like he was born
right in the middle of our uh you know
debt free journey and then right in the
middle of uh the pandemic starting up so
that was uh april 2020 having a baby's
not stressful at all it was totally fine
wow that's awesome wow so fantastic well
a couple things we're we're gonna give
you guys uh two gifts just to really
honor you
celebrate you one is a copy of dave's
total money makeover that you can give
to somebody else and it'll become a
paperweight for them for a while until
they decide to do something with it and
then dave's new book baby steps
millionaires comes out in january we're
going to give you a pre-release copy of
that because that's where you're headed
and you guys have got a great future so
let's do this let's get the kiddos are
they going to join us here for the there
they come there's finley right
and then axton yeah yes look at that
what a great name for a football coach's
son come here yes yes that's like
perfect i love it all right so have they
been practicing
um i don't know
they're really good at yelling i mean
he's that's perfect he's half
velociraptor it's cool
that's what we say about john around the
office exactly yeah so that's fine all
right let's do this we've got
justin and taylor finley in action from
dallas texas they paid off 89 000 in 24
months making 118
to 213 000
take it away let's hear your debt free
screen three two
one praise god
all right
[Music]
that's great look at that
axe is like what are we doing here dad i
was coloring it yeah are you let me eat
my candy cane yeah oh it's a candy cane
she loves it
fantastic stuff you know you'll love it
when you see
young kids on the debt free screen stage
with their parents because you know they
have no stinking clue they're going to
awesome their parents they're going to
be older so we lived at grandma's house
for a while yeah yep don't even remember
it at all times but yeah oh fun stuff
amazing oh that's why we do what we do
folks it's worth it you just heard it
don't move more of the ramsay show
coming up right around the corner
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america you are joining the
conversation here on the ramsey show i'm
ken coleman i'm joined in studio by my
colleague dr john delaney we're here for
you taking your phone calls about your
life
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five blinds dot com's 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure or pick the wrong color they
will remake your blinds for free we
could call that the ken coleman
uh condition because i'm the idiot that
would do all of those things john that's
why that actually exists that's why
they're a great company i'm another
level of idiot i don't have any blinds
i haven't even tried yet that's how
scared of him but yeah yeah so you get
free samples free shipping and with all
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey
and you will get the best deal today's
question comes from andrew in oklahoma
my girlfriend and i met in college and
have been dating for four years i left
school for a great job in i.t in school
i didn't know what i wanted to do but
realized when i took this job that it is
my passion my girlfriend just started
optometry school which is three hours
away and wants me to move there and get
married i want to get married but this
dream job just fell in my lap and i'm
having a hard time giving it up i think
a long distance relationship can work
and i'm willing to get married after she
finishes school and gets a full-time job
is it selfish of me to want to keep my
job for now hey doc i'm gonna let you
take a shot first and then i'll i'll
swoop in if uh if i feel necessary i've
got thoughts i
what do you think relationship guru so i
don't think this is a
job issue
i think somebody wants to get married
now and somebody wants to get married
later i
well well diagnosed and so
i think there's a relationship
that is much more rocky than the
previous four years might might let on
and we've come to a fork in the road i
don't recommend dating for seven years
three of those being long distance one
of you in grad school and one of you
working your dream job
um
this is a conversation that's not it's
gonna end up being a fight about school
or a fight about my dream job that's not
it
the conversation here is about our
relationship that's what i think
yeah i i don't think it's fair
and i don't mind you disagreeing with me
on this i don't think it's fair for her
to put that pressure on him
to move to where she's going to school
not where she's going to work but where
she's going to score everything
temporary for her to say hey i need you
to leave this thing that you love it's a
big part of of what you're doing and who
you are now right
i just think it's unfair for her to to
ask that
and vice versa right she gets into yeah
it's not right for him to go no you
can't go forget your dream yeah i agree
with that my my my thinking here is um
man
i've just the only optometry school that
she can go to
we don't know we don't have a job
there's not i.t jobs somewhere else in
hotel right so yeah that's where you're
going to have this impasse together
if somebody gets into med school and my
first thought is well what about me
that's a signal that you're not on the
same page relationally right wow um
tough yeah so my wife had a great job
and and that she loved and great
community there in texas and when i got
this job in nashville at the university
it was
i can't i can't wait to see what this
adventure is going to be right and it
was it would have been the same if she
got
some great opportunity tomorrow then it
would be about how can we do this thing
together not what about what about me
what about me so yeah they got to figure
out the together first that's right and
then the job stuff he tends to take care
of itself not always but maybe yeah
that's good all right let's get back to
the phones triple eight eight two five
five two two five ariana is joining us
now in los angeles how can we help
hey guys thanks so much for taking my
call
um
i finished grad school at the end of
2019
and um with about 71 000 in student
loans from that degree
and when covet happened and the interest
got paused and payments got paused i
really didn't make any payments but i've
still been saving money and as of a
couple days ago i have the money in my
account to pay off
that entire loan wow good for you
what's your degree in
thank you it's in consumer psychology
and i'm kind of doing something related
to it but consumer psychology is
depressing isn't
it is it's really depressing what is
because i think there's other people
listening that want to know details what
is consumer psychology it's one of my
favorites you you you explain it's one
of my favorite things but you explain it
ron you're you're the expert
yeah sure well my degree didn't imply
psychology and there was a focus on
consumer psychology so it's just
understanding the motivations of why
people make the decisions what they do
when they're purchasing but
i'm actually in kind of a
a different field went into something
different just because yes it was
depressing and it did not uh is it
depressing because is it depressing
because uh you now see uh how pathetic
humans are and how easily manipulated
manipulated they are to buy something
what's going on much much less free will
than we like to walk around believing
there is that's what i was thinking and
people make decisions based on
tribes not on rational thinking is that
fair ariana did i just describe your
graduate degree
yes
all right sorry i i was learning on
behalf of the audience so
why wouldn't you pay off the student
loans now because you have the money in
full why wouldn't you do right
i'm pretty confident that i'm gonna do
that um i've just been getting a lot of
conflicting advice from my parents and
financial planners that are kind of
advising
to buy a home instead or in court
instead
um just because they know i have that
money right now um because they're okay
with that can i talk to a real
psychologist for a second
yes okay so you know one of the core
tenets
of psychology one of the core tenets of
a person being
physiologically and psychologically well
is this idea of autonomy i have some say
however limited that might be
i have some limited control in what my
tomorrow might look like
and i have come to believe that when you
are in debt to somebody else to an
institution to a group to a vehicle loan
whatever that may be that you limit your
autonomy for tomorrow and i've come to
believe that you cannot be
psychologically whole if you owe
somebody else something if somebody else
is dictating your tomorrow actions
because of something you bought
yesterday
is that fair
yeah and i agree i think having a home
is so incredible uh so cool having your
own place
but if you pay this off you will wake up
tomorrow and go you know what i can do
anything i want because i owe nobody
that's right and you will get an awesome
home but now you're a lot less stressed
and you're going to be wealthy
yeah stop listening to other people what
advice would you give you're this is fun
i got two psychologists in here what
advice she's a real one i'm a pretend
one i'm a podcast host she's a real
psychologist i was trying to be nice to
you okay so what would you ariana what
would you say to you
seriously step out of the situation what
advice would you give you you want to
pay this off that's what you said and
you're getting conflicting advice
meaning opposite of what you want to do
parents and some goofball financial
advisor who's an idiot is telling you
something different what would you tell
yourself
um to trust my dad here and what i'm
hearing right now definitely solve for
freedom
you will wake up tomorrow free
free
ash i wish you could do it right now can
we pay it off while you're on the air we
got a minute and a half is it all set up
well i guess
i guess that's my
my next question would i would you guys
advise i just empty my account
uh yeah i think you're saying that the
wrong way would we advise that you pay
all this student loan off right right
now
because you have all of the money to do
it yes we would if that's the question
yes
and it will take you okay you're right
it'll take you three months
four months to have a fully funded
emergency fund
and then you think you know what freedom
is until you have no payments and a
fully funded emergency fund
and that's when the call is going to
come to say hey can you move to this
state for this particular job and you're
going to be able to laugh and go yeah
i'll be there tomorrow because right
that's right and i love that you said
that doc cause ariana the next thing is
you begin to focus on what is it that
you really want to do with your life in
every area
you're completely unchained
professionally
financially you're you're free john's
exactly right what are you waiting on
i'm hanging up on you right now you're
done
i didn't actually hang up on her we put
her on hold we never hang up on anybody
unless you're a jerk but here's the deal
it's time we just set one person free
ken coleman well we didn't do it she did
she's ready for her hard work but very
honest set yourself free like right now
like go do it right now what are you
waiting on
hey i want to thank our producer james
childs
our associate producer call screener
jenna sears i want to thank my pal john
deloney and you america you're listening
to the ramsay show
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show it's where america hangs out to
have a conversation about your life i'm
ken coleman i'm joined this hour in
studio by my colleague dr john deloney
and we are here for you
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five triple eight
eight two five
five two two five let's get to it from
the big apple new york city andrew is on
the line andrew how can we help
hey guys how's it going uh we're living
the dream what can we do for you
uh basically so right now i'm working an
accounts payable job uh making around 52
000 a year um 25 i have a degree in
business administration um
but i'm really unhappy in the position
and i kind of dread going to work every
day i dislike sitting in the office
and there's not a lot a whole lot of
room for growth
other than pay i get uh
a two two raises a year of two dollars
each per raise
um and the company right now i work for
is an hvac refrigeration service company
wait a minute you get a raise twice a
year of two dollars
yeah mm-hmm
well so far yeah that's that's what my
boss told me like usually every six
months i can expect a raise of two
dollars for this oh two dollars a per
hour gosh i thought it was annualized
you got that's true wondering where you
were going with the questioning oh sorry
yeah
per hour yeah all right andrew give him
just a minute it takes about five
minutes for the meds to kick in for him
he'll be there in just a minute i'll get
there all right all right so yeah this
is a dead end for you
this is a dead end yeah yeah a little
bit a little bit um and the company i
work for it's an hvac and refrigeration
company and i've been thinking about
transitioning into a role as a mechanic
in the field
because i i talked to the supervisor and
he said uh once i get my epa
certification i'd be good to go
um but in the beginning i would be
taking a pay cut uh to around twenty
dollars an hour but the mechanics get a
raise of six raises per year of one
dollar per hour usually all right so we
got a lot of we got a lot of money
flying around forgive me for my adhd
so you are making uh how much per hour
right now
25 25 and you'll drop to 20 uh for a
short amount of time
yeah yeah basically i'd be back up to 25
within about within about a year i'd be
back up to making 25 and probably a
little bit more all right so to me to me
it's not a money issue this is a meaning
issue right yeah you started off the
call going man i didn't want to go into
the office and the reason is because you
don't love the work that's passion and
the results of your work
while they're valuable they just don't
move you am i right
yeah all right so then i gotta ask i
want to put that same classification on
getting out there as a mechanic
will you really enjoy fixing stuff
uh do you get fired up uh seeing
problems solved are you are you a guy
who's motivated by solution
yeah yeah because i was um right after
college i was working just cutting grass
at a golf course and just the idea of
being outside and seeing a finished
product was more satisfying than you
know inputting invoices all day yeah so
i think i think i would yeah well
how much of this do you have a business
degree how much of this you're having to
swallow some
yeah uh i went and got a four-year
business degree and i'm gonna end up
working alongside guys who just went
straight to trade school
how much of that how much of that shame
are you carrying around
yeah there's a little bit of that
brother
hey i got a bunch of doctorate degrees
ken doesn't same job yeah get over it
yeah i do i do want to point out i have
no degree at all so i don't know i mean
i think that's kind of fun but i will
say this john i'm glad you pointed this
out there's a lot of sunk cost shame
there is and you just nailed it with
andre andrew did you hear what john said
yeah there's no shame in your game man
you didn't waste a bunch of time and
money i think that's what you think or
people think but it's no here's the deal
you're actually figuring this out how
you learned how young are you
i'm yeah i'm 25 right now come on
started yet brother yeah i love this
okay so here's the only other thing i'd
say i'd say this feels like an absolute
uh get after it
but just because i love
clarifying and verifying
i'd love for you and you may have
already done this
have you spent some time with any of the
techs that are that are doing what
you're doing now the guys that are that
are mechanics have you spent any time
with them to say hey give me a quick uh
give me a quick hi-lo
uh the ins and outs of what you do have
you spent any time with them on that
yeah i talked to one mechanic basically
every day he's kind of encouraging me to
do it because he kind of knows that i'm
unhappy
and it's
i mean there's good benefits the the job
is in the union after a while yeah but
i'm not hearing anything about the work
itself do you feel confident that you
got all your questions answered as it
relates to am i going to enjoy this
yeah i think i would i i think i would
definitely all right
i call it a soul tax when you stay in a
job that you don't like that's good
because it's two dollars an hour or more
whatever
it's costing you somewhere right it's
costing you somewhere and i'll also say
this a plumber came to my house today
with their gadgets to unclog my
you can help families
you help families that dude is more
important to sheila than you are let's
be honest question okay you want some
you want to find meaning in your work go
be a plumber be an electrician
they don't love us she can go to the
bathroom on the inside of the house
today
it's incredible that's fantastic a
plumber showed up to my house
yeah that's awesome yeah watch watch the
ac go out at the coleman house in the
middle of july
and the guy shows up and does an
incredible job yeah he's a little sweaty
he's a little dirty stacey don't care no
in my little she's like uh my skill set
my little pep talks they don't make the
house cooler oh i promise you i can't
coach an hvac system to work
i promise you that right now yeah i love
it all right let's go oh look at let's
just stay here shall we well we don't
know what burro andrew was in and we
don't know what borough jeff is in but
they're both in new york city let's see
if we can do this jeff you are on the
ramsay show how can we help
how are you guys thank you for taking my
call you bet we got about two minutes
let's see if we can help you what's up
i am calling about um home purchasing
okay
so right now i'm 35 years old um
family man wife three kids and i'm
looking for some advice on home
purchasing my first home
um currently
i make about 95k a year
um my only debt right now is a car loan
for about 19 000
and no other debt okay do you have any
savings at all
uh currently right now by the end of
this year i'll have about
75k saved 75 000 saved yes
okay are you familiar with our baby
steps
uh not so much but a little bit all
right john you want to walk you through
it yeah well so you want to
first before you buy a house before you
get any add any sort of risk to your
life i want you to pay off all of your
consumer debt so i want you to keep well
actually you don't even have to do that
i want you to write a check for that
nineteen thousand dollar car
today and be debt free today how much
cash do you have right now in the bank
right now
68. all right so at the end of this call
you're going to have 49 000 you're going
to be 100 debt free and then you're
gonna save up three to six months of an
emergency fund that's three to six
months of your expenses things go up or
to go down you're gonna buy a new house
the air conditioner's gonna break the
roof's gonna cave whatever you're gonna
save up three to six months of emergency
fund and then you're gonna save 10 to 20
down on your home and your home is not
going to be more than one fourth of your
take home income and if you meet those
numbers
you're in stay on the line we're going
to send you a copy of the total money
makeover that's going to walk you
through this jenna's going to get that
for you that's going to be our gift to
you as you start this new journey but
brother you're debt-free in about 13
minutes i want you to get online and pay
this thing off
yeah try to beat the 13-minute deadline
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
welcome back america you are listening
to the ramsay show i'm ken coleman dr
john deloney joining me this hour
thrilled to have you with us it is a
free phone call if you want to jump in
triple eight eight two five
five two two five if you've had it
with living paycheck to paycheck and
you're sick and tired of constantly
worrying about money
you don't have to live like that anymore
no matter how you've managed money in
the past or how much debt you have you
can take control of your money you just
need a plan and the right plan is
financial peace university it's helped
almost 6 million people take control of
their money one step at a time
you'll learn how to make a budget that
actually works pay off your debt spend
and save wisely and invest for your
future these numbers blow me away every
time i see them the average family in
financial peace university pays off 5
300 in debt and saves twenty seven
hundred dollars in their first 90 days
of the class we'll walk you through the
plan but it's up to you to step into it
and get started decide today financial
peace university is only available
through a ramsey plus membership get
started today or gift it to someone you
know by visiting ramseysolutions.com
fpu that's ramseysolutions.com
fpu tracy joins us now in cincinnati
ohio tracy how can we help
hello thank you for taking my call you
bet
um
my boyfriend um was laid off from july
this year um 65
hey tracy hey tracy talk directly into
the phone so we can hear you there you
go okay
um so he was going to try and retire
um
he he's a union welder
he was going to try and retire he has
found out that he does
not like retirement
he did start receiving his social
security
our problem is he still wants to work
but we don't know
how he's going to work and receiving
social security how much money he can
make
um how we're going to do all this
okay why don't you have the answers to
these problems and what what's the
source of this you're not doing your
homework i mean what what what's going
on there
well i mean we hit um somebody tells him
he can only make 18 000 a year
um we make very very good money
um he actually went back to work last
this week yeah he doesn't need to be
drawing from social security
that's that right so
dude if we and then he was told do we
stop that and are we going to get
penalized if we stop with social
security oh yeah i got to tell you off
the top of my head i don't know if
stopping receiving the payments creates
a penalty don't think i don't think it
does but here's the deal this is a phone
call to the social security
administration and you could get this
figured out i mean that's what you need
to do i wouldn't just operate in
ambiguity here but the real big issue is
the more important issue you can get an
answer to that okay so go get an answer
to it okay and and then stop it but he
doesn't need to be drawing from it he
loves to work he wants to work you guys
make really great money
uh so i would double check on all of
that you know does he can he draw from
it and still work all the nine yards i
i'm not the expert on that but this is
not hard for you to find out this is
just you know making a one phone call
maybe even getting online with the
social security administration and and
checking into that but um he just needs
to be staying active he needs to be
working so that's the better financial
move for him and for you guys
tracy i recommend if you're even
considering retirement even whether it's
a one year two years five have you all
sat down with a smart investor pro to
sit down and look at your numbers to see
can't is it even a viable option here
no i he has because um
like i said we're not married yet so
um he has absolutely no debt i'm paying
off mine right now okay
so um
that's all in the works um but i mean
he's got all because he's
he's uh um
he's an everyday millionaire okay um
so um so he's like
he likes working yeah yeah oh yes tell
them to stop drawing social security
and
keep working okay so i uh here's the
deal i'm on the social security uh
administration website if you change
your mind about starting your benefits
you can cancel your application for up
to 12 months how long has he been
receiving the payments
just for a couple months now it's not
that long yeah there is no penalty on
that so you can you can do that okay
okay yeah okay yeah good stuff but
here's the deal i want to be very clear
i'm glad you keep those finances
separate they're not married that's
right and so you know you got to do
what's best for you and he's got to do
what's best for him financially
i appreciate the call on his behalf but
yeah go ahead and pause that um right
now and i do like the idea of course
beginning with the smart investor
product okay once i reach what is this
the age of 70 uh you know and what's
this all going to look like how would i
invest that and everything else it's
good to have a really good plan and for
those of you getting up to 62 65 68 71
you
don't have to retire
so many people get there and say
well i guess i'm here i guess i should
just i have to quit i like working i
like going in i like accomplishing
things like serving people keep doing it
keep doing it
yeah i've got no intention of just
stopping
i i don't know i like working and i like
my life i like my job yeah you know i
think there's something to you know the
idea of staying active not just mentally
active but staying active emotionally
yeah because you know how i think
they're connected to a purpose yeah yeah
if you're doing work that you really
enjoy that's creating a result that's
touching the lives of some people and
you go it doesn't even matter if you
need the money anymore but staying
active
it it's reframing work and all of a
sudden it's contribution right what
contribution you want to make at 65. and
you get paid for it
game on i love that let's go to madison
wisconsin next matt is on the line there
matt how can we help hi guys thanks um
i'm looking i i'm trying to prioritize a
work-life balance with a significant
increase in in pay and benefits
my current situation i'm 32 my wife's
31.
you currently make 156 between the two
of us
um i can look at doubling my salary and
take us to about 198 if i took another
position with
a better retirement plan stuff like that
the issue is hours quite terrible hours
honestly
but
it's not so much
that i would have to do that long term
it'd be for a few years until i got
my rental properties paid off i could
grind it out for four or five years
do that
and then look look at something with a
better balance so how do i
i don't want to
let me let me let me jump in we got
about two minutes i want john to jump in
on this one obviously um i'd like to
simplify these questions
um
so
you're only considering this
because of the bump getting you to a
place of paying off your rentals so it's
a part of your debt-free journey that's
the only reason you're even considering
this correct
well not necessarily
i have a lot of intrinsic rewards that
position i have now right my boss is
tough to deal with ah
so that's piece of information we didn't
have so the next question i have is
this this sucks on the outset
we forget the salary for a moment the
way you describe this these hours are
going to be pretty darn awful your words
i believe correct yeah
yeah well i mean is it worth dealing
with awful
for two years
to well to pay off the debt and escape
your boss or
could you consider
uh another side hustle or another job
where you make a little bit of a bump
and you and you wait a little longer i
just wonder what the sacrifice is worth
john your thoughts on that yeah i've
seen i i've made that sacrifice and we
went into it with a shorts knowing this
is going to be a short season this is
going to be hard and it's always 10x
harder than you think but you can do it
for a short season that's right four or
five years seems
well that's right i can get
if i double my salary i can pay off my
properties in four years what i'm
currently that would be five years so
that's
that's the time savings i'm looking for
how many properties you got
five
okay what you've boxed yourself into an
either or what if you sold one of them
or two of them and you had three paid
off properties in two years
and then you've got your memories and
i've talked about that but they all make
good money all right here's the deal
yeah it's hard but you you're gonna pay
a tax either way you're gonna pay a tax
on your soul you can pay tax on your
marriage divorce courts real expensive
uh or have three paid for house can we
at least look for another job that
doesn't have sucky hours that can make
you more money i just think we're
looking at well i'm in a current
situation i got all these good things my
boss is a jerk i got this new thing
double my salary allowing me to pay off
my rental prices but it's going to be
awful for my life and we're not looking
at a third option which is well they're
not going to sell the rental properties
fourth option yeah
fourth option go get a really good job
with not sucky hours it pays you more
money so you got to look at all of it
all right tough stuff but you can make
the decision this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show america
thrilled to have you with us i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr john
dolone we're here taking your calls
triple eight eight two five five two two
five and it's always fun when you look
across the lobby there on the debt free
stage we see shanique and harold
welcome hey hi hi thank you so much for
having us
you're here where are you from well
we're i'm originally from florida i'm
from louisiana well we moved here well
we we came here from atlanta we live in
atlanta right now we're in atlanta we're
in sugar hill come on yeah you're right
next door to sewanee
[Music]
you lived in their neighborhood i think
they're way better looking than you john
i was aware of this did you have to
point that out to everybody else for
those of you not listening not watching
yeah it's a fantastic looking couple
well that's fantastic great great great
so you're up here to do a debt free
screen we are all right let's go through
the numbers here we go how much did you
pay off we paid off
175 000 whoa
how long did that take it took us two
and a half years to do it wow that's
getting what's still smoking that's a
lot of money wow
herculean yeah i'm surprised you both
are standing
uh yeah yeah yeah all right we'll get
into that all right and then range of
income during that time well i would say
it was like 97 to 160 000. great what do
you guys do for a living i'm a doctor of
audiology and i'm a graphic designer i
work at cnn yeah oh really yeah okay
great that's fantastic i love it doctor
of audiology yeah specializing in
hearing issues yes hearing imbalance
yeah okay great great guy right all
right okay so real quick i keep hearing
that because we all walk around with ear
pods shoved in our our heads that we're
starting to hear a little bit worse and
worse and worse is that as
a culture what did you say
exactly just turn it down just a little
you should okay hold on hold on
i gotta tell you medical advice james i
can't go forward until i feel like she's
a little loud in my ear and i'm feeling
convicted about it all right now okay
doc we're good okay all right so uh what
happened
two and a half years ago where you guys
said we're getting rid of this debt
well i would say it started with a car
loan that um well our car loans that we
had and i was making the
usual payments and that just felt as
though we weren't getting anywhere and
once i logged in
to that
lender i noticed that really most of the
payments were going to interest and that
just
it bothered me so much so i just i told
my husband like hey we i just can't do
we can't do this we need to
just figure something out so somehow i
came across dave's videos and i guess
you can say we were gazelle intensive
what else was in the 175 some loans
student loans i'm guessing student loans
yeah majority student loans majority
student loans in the car yeah two cars
yeah so you're very normal very normal
yeah yeah no big deal everybody's doing
that yes yes wow yes very interesting
yeah so who who sat down at the table
and had the conversation with who
um pretty much um she pretty much laid
the majority of it i could tell by the
looks
yeah i would say yeah it was definitely
me but i couldn't do it without my
husband so how did you receive it harold
when she brought this to you um i pretty
much i was i was down for it the whole
time um i've always been a person who's
always been like i guess
tight pockets in this instance about um
but when she came to me um she kind of
had a plan and a kind of a step by step
playing when she started watching you
guys and i was down for it the whole
time yeah i love it so what what kept
y'all going for for two and a half years
that's a that's a long time yeah the
yeah let's do it that wears off in a
month or two oh yeah and then you're
like whoa now we're in it sooner than
that um
but for the most part we just kept going
we didn't necessarily like our family
and our friends they knew about it um
but they didn't necessarily get it so i
would say like our biggest support was
from you guys like the dave ramsey
community just
social media youtube and things like
that although we didn't have that those
one-on-one conversations just being a
part of the facebook group you know that
goes a long way just about information
yes so so
how much grief did you take i mean
you're rolling into cnn and you're
driving the old car and you're driving
up you know your dock oh she's the good
doctor and like is that that's that's
the car that a doctor drives you bring
in your lunch to work doc yeah like how
did y'all navigate the the comparison
challenges ah
well i guess like with us
i guess the results start coming in and
you kind of see what happened throughout
the time period you see like your debt
is being knocked down
so like when you're looking at you know
uh the income like i guess the actual
debt going away you kind of get you know
motivated more and more each time it's
like we're almost here we got like you
know a year left you know some months
left and you finally get to that point
so you just so you by watching the the
debt get paid off those loud voices just
get quieter and quieter yeah much
quieter we didn't even we no longer
cared about what people had to say like
oh you guys are so cheap or something
that's okay we we have a fully funded
emergency fund
we can give and help others like we are
comfortable where we are that's so good
wow so i'm looking at two
get after it people it's just obvious
you said we went gazelle i want people
to hear what did that look like for you
guys how intense what'd you do what was
some of the crazy just like you're a
maniac
you got something for us um we stuck to
our budget and when it comes to you
might think this is crazy but for the
two and a half years that we were on the
plan um leading up to paying off our
debt um we only spend like 120 on
groceries every single month okay break
that house look at this guy this is an
athlete yeah he looks like one what how
do you feed that man 120 a month what
were you feeding him we shop sales um
like i always pull out the circular i
look it up i buy things based off sales
i buy in bulk i have a deep freezer meal
prep
you're using yeah what were you eating
you were intentional say what
you mean you planned your life
intentional is the worst for sure you
have to be disciplined and intentional i
just need to know i p the american
people are waiting to hear was it rice
and beans or something else you know
rice it was but other things
vegetables
like for a minute we stopped eating meat
i mean we're eating chicken and things
like that now but for a while okay we
didn't that's serious business yeah
definitely yeah that's not messing
around
as well yes yeah that too so you made it
uh your side hustle was
cutting the grocery cost yeah absolutely
cutting any cost that we could so yeah
good for you wow see i love that i do
too i love it i love the intensity okay
yeah a lot of people listen to you okay
what would you say each of you take a
stab at this what would you say is the
key to making it through this two and a
half years of intensity
i would say
just
remembering your why and not allowing
outside influences to get into or to um
disturb or impede what the things that
you're trying to do so just keep going
and don't allow anyone to influence you
no matter what head down yes love it
absolutely what do you got for us harold
um i would say
um leaning on each other um i feel like
we've grown a stronger bond together
through this journey depending on each
other and i'll learn to trust each other
um definitely you know uh following her
letting them lead this and you know
walking with each other and you know we
also like you know depending on as far
as ideas what can we do as far as like
money wise so i would definitely say
lean on each other yeah i love it and
god as well
well i got to tell you we got a couple
things for you here uh to to kind of
reward you and honor you uh one is
dave's total money makeover book for you
to give to somebody else okay if you
believe ninja and then we're gonna give
you an advanced copy of dave's new book
first book he's written in eight years
baby steps millionaires because that's
who you are going to be very very soon
so we're going to give you that and then
uh we also want to bring champion the
coolest name i wish my name was champ
coleman and this is champ how old is
champ champ is 19 months he's 19 months
look at that stud look at that guy he
has no idea how awesome his parents are
but we all do so here we go you guys
ready to do your thing we are all right
so we've got shanique uh harold and
champ from sugar hill georgia i got to
throw that in there uh they paid off uh
175 000 in debt in two and a half years
making 97 to 160 thousand dollars take
it away it's time for your debt free
screening ready count yeah three
two
one
we're
[Applause]
[Music]
love
deaf
it's awesome champ kept the uh passy in
the whole time
he's a champ you're free brother you're
free you are free that is so great what
an awesome story what an awesome family
that's what peace looks and sounds like
right there folks don't move more the
ramsay show coming right up
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm ken coleman
i'm joined by my colleague and ramsey
personality dr john deloney thrilled to
have you with us triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the number to
jump in
today's scripture james 5 16. therefore
confess your sins to each other and pray
for each other so that you may be healed
the prayer of a righteous person is
powerful and effective our quote today
from john wesley oh this is one of my
favorites john
do all the good you can
by all the means you can in all the ways
you can in all the places you can at all
the times you can to all the people you
can as long as you ever can
only if only only a methodist preacher
like john wesley and writer can say it
that powerfully that effectively i mean
that just
that's pretty much you want to know why
you're on the planet that's your life
right there that's purpose that's it you
do that
and the rest takes care of itself life
is going to be really
really really special good stuff there
all right let's uh stay right here in
our backyard nashville tennessee annie
is here annie how can we help
hi thank you guys so much for uh taking
my call
um so my husband and i i'm 24 he's 25 we
have no debt we have a fully funded
emergency fund and we are saving up to
buy our first house
we both have awesome sets of parents who
paid for our college and gave us cars
and just want to say they did awesome so
it really does work
um
but now we're kind of in the market for
a car my husband's car is not the best
um what is it what kind of car it's a
it's an 08 hyundai azera nice how many
miles and
it's got 175 000 miles on it
so which isn't horrible like we were
planning on driving it until we like i
had to go pick him up on the side of the
road or something but um okay we can get
it we can pay to get it fixed it's gonna
cost about two thousand dollars but we
thought why don't we just keep saving up
money we're like i said we're saving up
for a house
so we i mean we have some cash we can
pay for a car but we've just been like
doing research about getting a car and
the market is you know off the chain
right now but we just wanted to know why
you guys teach we should pay ourselves
first like keep paying
monthly like we're paying a car payment
and then paying cash whereas we've also
seen people say like
um get the loan but then pay it off as
soon as you can because that's the car
dealer will give you the best deal if
you don't say you're going to pay in
cash and or we were just wondering why
you teach because pay for it fully in
cash because
the philosophy behind this is because
most people i forget what the new number
is but it used to be about 450 a month
it may be as high as five six hundred
dollars a month is the average car
payment and you're and you're paying
that on a depreciating asset so you buy
it for one price which by the way you're
gonna buy you're gonna pay premium for a
used car right now even from a dealer
it's gonna be it's premium you're paying
you're overpaying right now and if you
don't pay cash so now you're carrying
around those payments okay so let's just
use round numbers okay and let's say you
got a 500 a month car payment and you're
paying interest on that okay so that's
500 plus and it's a higher interest rate
all right and so you're you're that car
you're driving around and it's going
down investment every down there's less
money less money and and you're still
under pressure to pay off that debt as
opposed to if you spend 2 000 right now
to fix the hyundai
and you keep saving up and let's say you
paid yourself
500 a month towards a car replacement
right let's say that becomes one of your
line items it should be you guys have no
debt
and so or maybe you remove some of that
money from the house payment you get a
really nice dependable car and then
after we get the nice dependable car
that's going to be less in mechanical
cost obviously then we go back into
saving for the house there's no
viable reason it's horrible it's a bad
decision to have a car payment because
you're paying more every every month
than you should be paying and it's
depreciating in value and so let me tell
you this just down the street from you i
i went and bought a new car not a new
car but i used a new to me car um maybe
a month ago now i just did as well and i
went over to a dealership here in
nashville and i wrote a check for it and
then i went home
and
i don't have to worry about what's this
thing worth and is it losing value
i don't care i just shook the person's
hand and said i'll give you this for
that and
they did give me a run around because
like well if you finance it you can say
they did because that's where they're
gonna make their money
and i said man look i'm gonna write you
a check let's let's let's walk out and
what i'll tell you is i haven't thought
about it twice since because we saved
that money up and there's no pressure
there's no worry there's no whatever
what's going to happen is you're going
to say to yourself we'll just pay it off
as fast as we can
and then the air conditioner is going to
break or then your car is going to have
an issue or you're going to find the
greatest deal on the one and only home
that's available ever in the world ever
ever
and then you're going to find yourself
in a mess
so
i would rather see you drive
i bought that new car from my wife my
car is an 08 no it's an o6 it's an o6
it's older than yours same amount of
miles and it's just putting along just
fine and that that's my recommendation
until you've got the money pay for your
house and
pay for these cars cash you guys have to
just determine what's the greater
priority the down payment on the home or
having a car that's not going to be a
nuisance to you and this car is getting
into nuisance territory now there's a
reason it can't go for another 75
000 miles and by the way annie remind
you what you said at the start of the
call our plan was is to drive it until i
had to pick him up on the side of the
road now you're faced with a two
thousand dollar repair and you're going
well maybe we'll take on some debt well
so here's what happens so when you go
look for a home like here's our price
range let's make up a number let's say
it's 300 000. and the realtor says well
let me show you this one it's 450 but
let me show it to you and they show you
that one and then every house you look
at after that is ruined yeah
because it's not that
same as we're just going to drive this
to the wheel falls off we don't look at
other cars we don't think about other
cars and then you think well before we
get it fixed let's let's look at these
other cars yeah you hop over to a
website and start looking at cars
and now your car suddenly looks awful
and you hate your life
i'd go get it fixed and keep driving it
that's what i would do
because it sounds like the house is more
of a desire right so drive the hyundai a
little bit longer two grand for a car
repair please you guys are debt free
you're cool take it off yeah i think you
now should actually i think i'm gonna
hold you to your words drive this thing
until it literally dies on the side of
the road then you go by and in fact i
want you to drive out here next week to
the ramsey solutions building and me and
ken will take a photo with this hyundai
it's fantastic john says he'll lay on
the hood
he'll lay on the hood of the car with a
christmas wreath it's gonna be fantastic
absolutely all right let's go to maria
in anchorage alaska maria how can we
help
hi um well i'm looking for
some uh support and guidance okay i
right now i'm a stay-at-home mom i was a
cma a certified medical assistant
and i am looking to change my career
i am looking into nursing
i had been wanting to do this for the
past 10 years and i've been to school so
i have some credits but
[Music]
along the way i've had many things
happen
and like getting bad grades so now
i guess i don't have the confidence
and that's what i'm calling you don't
have confidence to be a nurse to to to
step forward
um
i feel like i don't have the confidence
to
go through through it like
through the program like
i
sometimes i i don't have self um
discipline
so i feel like it's going to be hard for
me and that's something that i'm
learning about myself why do you choose
to not have self-discipline
because it's a choice why do you choose
that
i don't know
want you to hear me say these words i
want you to tattoo them on your soul
you are worth discipline
and if you will if you will choose
discipline even when it's hard
especially when you don't feel like it
you will open up everything
because nobody else is disciplined
nobody else gets up and works out when
it's cold outside nobody else studies
exactly when the tv's on it's it is wide
open for anybody in this country who
wants to step into the to the and walk
the steps of being a disciplined life
it's a choice yeah it's a choice
you're worth it you said you want to
change how bad do you want it
tell me um quickly how bad do you want
to be bad pretty bad all right then so
you know what this issue is john's right
nobody wakes up on their own because
they're thrilled at 5 am to work out
they want to get in shape and they got
to remind themselves of 5 a.m why they
want it that gets them out of bed i
think that's got to be your focus your
desired future you better keep your eyes
on that the discipline will show up hey
i want to thank my colleague dr john
delonia i want to thank our producer
james childs our associate producer and
call screener jenna sears and you
america thank you for listening this is
the ramsay show
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
you